bonjour avec six poulains merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a vu le conseil d'état a censuré
les lois de l'exécutif est ce que c'est
un avertissement avant la fin du
quinquennat dans un peu plus d'un an
maintenant un peu moins d'un an
oui on a l'impression effectivement que
le conseil d'état reste le dernier
contre pouvoir face à monaco et sa
volonté de réforme coûte que coûte les
dernières sanctions sur le climat le
président et son gouvernement n'en font
pas assez bien sûr sur la forme de
l'assurance chômage qui arrive au même
moment après la crise sanitaire sur les
techniques de nas techniques de sécurité
lors des manifestations et puis lors de
la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
sanctions sur l'interdiction de sortie
des résidents d pad mais aussi
l'utilisation des drones pour filmer les
malheureux citoyens qui aurait osé
sortir dehors lors déconfinement donc
beaucoup de choses qui ont d'ailleurs
agacé le chef de l'état qui aurait dit
que ce n'était pas au niveau que le
conseil d'état était là comme une cour
de justice de province que ce n'était
vraiment pas ce qu'il attendait de cette
instance instance qu'il faut rappeler et
héritier en quelque sorte un des
conseils du roi qui est là pour
conseiller justement le chef de l'état
l'exécutif dans la façon dont il va
faire les lois donc ça en dit long sur
la pratique législative des macros et sa
façon aussi d'aborder les
contre-pouvoirs donc je crois qu'il ya
là effectivement une volonté de tempérer
celle des manades macron celle de
réforme coûte que coûte en disant qu'il
faut peut-être attendre et le conseil
d'état d'ailleurs n'est pas entièrement
contre la politique du gouvernement
puisque par exemple une association de
photojournaliste avait demandé à accéder
aux tentes des migrants à calais lorsque
les forces de l'ordre les antillais et
leur empêcher d'accéder à ses tantes et
là le conseil d'état n'avait pas accepté
cette requête donc lui c'est un conseil
qui travaillent et qui sans doute est en
train de préparer aussi la suite de du
quinquennat des modèles maquereau en
disant que tout ne peut pas aller aussi
vite l'état a aussi son rythme à
respecter alors après cette censure hein
de la part du conseil d'état quelle a
été la réponse de la république en
marche
quelle a été la réponse
l'elysée est est-ce qu'on se dirige vers
peut-être un bras de fer législatif
alors au bras de fer non puisque les
fonctions sont bien définis dans le
cadre de la constitution et puis il faut
dire que la réponse de l'exécutif c'est
plutôt face à ce que ce café l'exécutif
notamment la référente de la fonction
publique la réforme de l'ena par
emmanuel macron ce serait plutôt la
réponse du conseil d'état face à cela
parce que le nouveau responsable du
conseiller d'état bruno lasserre qui se
définit lui même comme un pape de
transition entre guillemets est là
jusqu'en janvier et doit réformer cette
institution avec de nouvelles règles de
recrutement avec nous verrait aussi de
fonctionnement est clairement le conseil
d'état a peur que la réforme des corps
d'état voulue par m le maquereau
n'amoindrissent bien sûr son rôle de
contrôle de conseil et le rendre caduque
en quelque sorte donc il ya le bras de
fer est engagé par enel mâcon dans sa
volonté de réforme de la fonction
publique sachant qu'il n'ya pas que le
conseil d'état qui est en ligne de mire
on a aussi d'autres conseils d'autres
instances de contre-pouvoir et qui sont
là pour sanctionner les politiques
publiques qui risque de se voir affublé
par par cette réforme donc effectivement
on peut parler d'un bras de fer en
quelque sorte entre ce qui serait l'état
l'état au delà de la politique et
l'exécutif élu pour cinq ans qui
souhaiterait et bien imprimer de sa
marque pour longtemps dans la façon dont
sont gérées les affaires dans ce pays et
alexis poulain pourquoi cette
accélération justement du calendrier des
réformes à saman alors pour les données
macro c'est clair c'est avoir un bilan
qu'il va pouvoir défendre sa réélection
s'il souhaite se représenter pour 2022
on a vu que toutes les réformes s'était
arrêté suite à la crise sanitaire du coc
vide donc il veut reprendre
il est question bien sûr de ré engager
les réformes de l'assurance chômage
malgré cette sanction par le conseil
d'état qui simplement donner un avis
redisant qu'il fallait attendre et il
donnera un avis plus tard sur la
faisabilité ou non de cette réforme la
réforme bien sûr des retraites qui va
revenir également tout est fait pour que
comme le disait le porte parole du
gouvernement
les réformes soient mises en place avant
la fin du quinquennat pour aller
chercher la croissance le rebond sans
poser le crayon ce sont les termes du
porte-parole du gouvernement
donc on voit bien qu'il ya une frénésie
de la part de l'exécutif pour aller au
plus vite et ne pas prêter le flanc à la
critique puisqu'ils émanent allemagne
quoi rappelez-vous été élu sur un projet
de réforme profonde de l'état du pays et
on voit bien que tout s'est arrêté en
cours de route donc ils souhaitent le
reprendre et d'où d'ailleurs cette
suractivité en quelque sorte du conseil
d'état qui doit vraiment vérifier toutes
ces lois qui s'accumulent et qui parfois
sont faites en dépit du cadre de la
constitution et du droit
c'est le rôle encore une fois de cette
institution
merci beaucoup alexis foulant d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes notre
éditorialiste merci beaucoup